die ersten luftangriffe des zweiten
weltkriegs treffen polen zunächst die
kleinstadt wir nun deutsche kampfflieger
zerstören und 70 prozent des städtchens
wenig später treffen die bomben auch ihr
hauptziel aschau die erste großstadt die
systematisch von den nazis bombardiert
wird
knapp ein jahr später steht london unter
beschuss in den nächsten monaten werden
dadurch mehr als 10.000 menschen getötet
die schwerste zerstörung erleiden die
briten aber in coventry deutsche bomber
treffen die industriestadt schwer wie
die nazis gilt fortan konzentrieren als
synonym dafür städte auszuradieren in
den ersten kriegsjahren verbreiten die
wehrmacht und ihre verbündeten schrecken
und zerstörung in ganz europa zeitgleich
entwickelt die britische luftwaffe unter
generator harris ihre strategie gegen
nazi-deutschland die deutsche
bevölkerung soll getroffen und zermürbt
und damit der krieg aus der luft
entschieden werden
am schlimmsten trifft es hamburg ende
juli 1943 die operation gomorrha
verwandelt große teile der hafenstadt in
ein trümmerfeld mehr als 30.000 menschen
sterben im feuersturm so viele wie bei
keinem anderen angriff
der bombenkrieg der alliierten trifft
überwiegend zivilisten er hat eine halbe
million menschen verlieren ihr leben
drei monate vor kriegsende bomben fallen
auf eine der letzten unversehrten
großstädte in deutschland
oberbefehlshaber harris ortet
luftangriffe gegen dresden an die
innenstadt danach nur noch schutt und
asche verfälschte dokumente geben eine
zeitlang 250.000 opfer an
später stellt sich heraus jemand hat der
zahl eine null angehängt in wirklichkeit
waren es bis zu 25.000 opfer zu werden
die ruinen der dresdner frauenkirche
nach kriegsende zum symbol für das
kriegsleid der deutschen 75 jahre danach
auch symbol der versöhnung
[Musik]